good you picked up that EXO naturally oh
yes okay we're all holding something I'm
not you uh put my hand fingers every
time in Robo Popo news Robo Cop does he
shoot people in the dick
you can yeah submitted by shooting
people in the dick entire day winging it
so this is a article about it's titled a
Robocop a park in a fight how
expectations about robots are clashing
with reality so I guess in Huntington
Park they're starting to put in these
clothes yeah yeah they're starting to
put in these like robot robotic I'll
just show you a picture robot we talked
about shakers yeah so um so then I guess
these are these robots are patrolling
around the parks to give people more
peace of mind they're there to you know
some if something happens or whatever
they've got like a panic button or
whatever you can press on it so
hopefully you know people can you know
police can come and respond to whatever
is going on and it's just supposed to be
people feel a little bit safer but this
particular instance it didn't work very
well because it's according to did
someone go behind it which is where the
robot is just moving along and it just
like drowns itself in a committed
suicide Salt Lake Park there's a fight
that broke out and then a woman came up
and pressed the emergency alert button
and she said it's pressing the button
and it but it said step out of the way
and I kept pushing pushing yeah so
apparently in that particular instance
due to work out so well so that's push
it too many times
the button just wasn't working good look
look here I don't know what what what
this robots deal is or what this lady's
deal is but like let's just give the
benefit of the doubt
right like where she just pushed it one
too many times or just kept reciting
that sounds like that sounds like a
problem though because if I design
something you're someone panicking
president biden said I was chewing on
this like what it's like when one's
right it's one those double push ones we
let you push it and it locks in place
you know doing that like now realizes
like no yeah bad design no it's good
design because then they keep from
having false calls of someone pushing it
like oh I didn't mean to bump into this
sorry officer but you like the cops are
coming if I did you know we not that we
hockey with the switch where you get the
president three times before you can
like actually activate when you see in
movies and TV shows right you push the
pack like what song pushes the panic
button it's only once you don't see them
bullying yeah push it once and run I
totally get it when you're in danger
like your mind goes into panic mode and
you just can't help but push it multiple
times but I'm just saying out of
practicality of this whole [ __ ] thing
right
maybe she pushed it one too many times
if we go based on movies and TV which I
know that's all fictional right they
only do it once and everything happens
you know like safety features come in
and whatnot everything but everybody
gets saying it shouldn't reset the
request ticket if you send it it's not
gonna be like oh there's a second part
that burger you press it a third time
it's right there bro god no it's all for
the same instance what are you practical
about the whole thing like this like
this thing it doesn't make sense I do I
just call it Anglin on your foot that's
the funny thing is that they followed it
up with nobody responded so that
somebody else called 18 minutes later
showed up you see here's where she
messed up is because if you look at the
shape of it it's perfect cuz basically
which is you hit the button as a little
trap door that opens up in a little
office
[Applause]
like step back ma'am I can't exit
blocking the trapdoor [ __ ] hilarious
look at that father clock with a little
like the bird comes out with a billy
club opening they come out it's like an
entire like trouble boom did not come
into it because I was imagining just one
I was imagining that just one guy it's
not it's just a guy in there all riled
up and he beats you up they hug you like
the chest if it opens up and absorbs the
person in and then they go shooting off
to the nearest precinct I don't know
welcome my new robot overlords exactly
when you push the panic button is it
supposed to connect you like the park
security or like legit the police I
think the intent is supposed it doesn't
specify in the in the article here but I
think it's supposed to like basically
call 9-1-1 or alert somebody to come
damn phone yeah but I mean I get the
idea of these robots but it's
interesting because later on the article
it's kind of an op-ed so it goes into
talking about different people how
different people feel about having the
robots there it's like you know at
college you have those help those yeah
it's moving yeah so for some people they
said that some people are a little
uneasy about it oh my god it looks kind
of weird like I don't know how I filled
our robots like wandering around is like
you know watching us and stuff and then
other people say that they're they like
it because they feel safer and I get
that especially when your brain family's
there and stuff like that if you're
worried about the safety of your kids
and stuff like it makes sense but
overall this particular instance I'm
sure did not leave a great-tasting this
more prisons around rather have
something like that we're like one of
those like Boston University ones and
then they're like oh they can run it
it could be like that foot so I don't
know about that I'm okay with the
slow-moving I salt shakers to have it
come after you because you can outrun it
whereas the Boston Dynamics and ones
isn't gonna like oh my job it will never
get entire yeah the one that can walk
those stairs and terminators is it a
terminator one are we talking about like
a little no no it's a giant salt shaker
yeah and then but though the last thing
is the out with the because the police
respond to this they're like okay well
the robots aren't necessarily there to
enforce all the laws or whatever it's
more or less to collect data as the way
they put it and that to me makes me a
little bit uneasy because I don't know
how I feel like about them how many
times will this lady push me until
something comes watching people and
stuff it just gives me very like 1980 or
84 right yeah or well Ian vibes there
but that's that's mine I'm okay with
that kind of stuff as long as it doesn't
answer my home like I'm more afraid of
like the Alexa and [ __ ] hey I unplugged
my Google home because I was just
letting you know I don't I don't need it
I use this to set alarms and to get the
weather and I listen to it yeah now
Apple say that I kinda believe with
Apple with the whole same with how they
do face ID and touch ID is stored on the
phone not on any kind of like systems I
know iCloud rings like that and federal
government has tried to pull information
to Apple and they were like hey no [ __ ]
them for that [ __ ]
so I do kind of trust them out on that
front a little bit but still like the
fact that Syria here's my conversations
you like that a weird weird cuz it's
like okay it's still stored on my phone
but like who's stopping them from
getting access to my phone especially
when you refurbish your phone and you
give it back like it's like I don't know
it just gives me weird vibes I mean
granted like I say that now but like to
be honest if it's late if it comes down
to us already talking about getting in a
constellation thing you guys are on
ghoul it's completely open like little
agreement you signed is like yeah we you
can take whatever you want one of them
what I mean is that a lot of people I
think me included will talk about like
privacy concerns and stuff like that and
yet it's sort of like we've signed over
so much already it's sort of like
[ __ ] like what if I wanted to
reverse all that where do I start
like I mean all of us are on Facebook
yeah all of us on Facebook Instagram
like I'm daily like you can
they're basically everyone's basically
fallen when you say when you say
followers literally means followers I
can follow my day from start to finish
if I decide to like in vlog I like post
about it you know and we're how much I
care to close like my girlfriend is
always bringing out about like [ __ ] like
that I'm like but I ain't doing [ __ ]
like yeah that's the other argument
you're seeing if someone but government
officials like alright cool you knew
that I have [ __ ] PR and jelly for ya
watch some twitch streamer today like
I'll give a [ __ ] and that's and that's a
feeling where most people stand on it
because that's where I sort of stood on
it for a while too as I was like well
I'm not doing anything illegal so why
should I you know care but it's sort of
that thought experiment you know freedom
of you know the freedom to once once
something that I you know something that
I identify with or something that I am
or something like that becomes illegal
then it's sort of like Walda although
things are already set in a place to
like
do you about me yeah what look at the
air so robot salt shakers and privacy
I'm like who is the ruler at the time
because governments or just any kind of
nation in history thrive under good
Kings are good until Oleg our key but
the thing that's not exactly it's like
once that shifts and then you have
someone who's [ __ ] up then it's like
oh I don't want you to listen to
anything I've got going on no before
it's like yeah sure go get the criminals
who are really trying to hide something
but they wants to be coming to someone
else yeah especially if you are aligned
with those ideals that that you know
good ruler is with you know as long as
you align with those that set of like
circumstances and rules and stuff it's
like yeah it's great until if they move
the goalposts and then all the sudden
all the things that you believed yeah
now over here in believe all this don't
feel as good anymore so that's I guess
that's the one thing that I'm concerned
about a lot of this is just me talking
out loud FBI is listening right now yeah
but I think it's I think it's a good
thing to think about especially in this
age well we're all we were all like
posting our lives online we're all like
sharing with our friends and not to talk
about about all of it because really
like it's affording me a lot of you know
actual friendships and like ways to
connect with people that I don't think
anybody could have ever [ __ ] imagined
like you know even five years ago you
know much less like you know how many
years past that before we got the
internet and see you guys look at you
see a saltshaker which you don't realize
flip upside down it's a top all right so
all I have to do is it rolls over
balances on its top spikes come out the
side they're like they're making these
you gotta know what this is really about
you're like I see an assault shaker like
a completely different with this that's
a good joke right there thanks I try
[Music]